welcome back to the iced coffee hour i
am charlie from charisma on command and
this podcast so far has made 212
thousand dollars of ad revenue hey no
that's close that's close yeah if we
compare that with our other guests
that's close
yeah it's compared to the other guests
yeah you came in you're like i watched
the other episode 160 but then you said
it was old yeah i didn't expect you
you'd say that much
well it's 163. okay
slower growth than i'd originally
anticipated
what yeah not the best no it's not but
but this was the worst january in in
going back the last like four years
compared to december for us too at rpms
yeah everything's down 25
yeah
with views down we're at a third of what
we were in december
yeah man so i had to sell the house
oh wow no no we're fine we're good
that's not where most of our money comes
in but we can talk about all of that
let's talk about i'm looking forward to
it so you've had a channel now going on
seven years right so that makes you
officially you're an og youtuber yeah i
was like second generation
the ogs the joey graceffa's and all
those people at vidcon i i remember
going to my first vidcom and looking at
them and not feeling in the same league
as them but yeah we've been doing it
since 2014 was the first video i put up
but we didn't really catch any traction
until 2016 or so when we started doing
the breakdown style that i think we've
become more known for these days so for
those that don't know charisma on
commission maybe your audience doesn't
know this yeah
yeah
is a youtube channel where basically
they teach people like tips and tricks
how to be more charismatic how to get
people to like you how to tell funny
jokes that don't hurt other people uh
how to be the most confident person in
the room stuff like that yes so
self-help stuff you know what the funny
thing is i've been recommended so many
of your videos because you have this few
videos every now and then that just pop
off that just kept showing up in the
homepage and i know just like even even
before all of this years ago i know i
know i've seen the channel before yeah
and i think a lot of people have yes i
think people they don't realize it
because it's not like a face that is
often associated with so we did a video
predicting that trump would win the
presidency early on in his presidential
run we've got some of the most famous
marvel actors i think they think of us
as like a screen rant sometimes or some
faceless corporation but really it's
it's mostly me and ben and ivan and a
handful of other people behind the
scenes nothing nothing too crazy or
complicated it is crazy because i
remember the first time i met you was uh
at vidsummit and this was october was it
october that time and uh i recognized
the name charisma on command but i
didn't really recognize like i didn't
recognize you nor ben and uh and then i
looked back and i like saw your videos
and the types of videos you made and i
was like wow i've watched so many of
these over the course of like the last
like three four years it's just like
randomly shows up in my feed i'm like
how can i be more charismatic yeah
exactly what yeah he made such a good
first impression no [ __ ] joke you i
told you this right what was the what
did jack do what do you do okay so when
you're at when you're at vid somebody
you were there uh
there's this
uh idolization thing that can happen
when people introduce themselves to you
and they get really nervous and they put
you on a pedestal and it can be
alienating and then there's the reverse
where people play it way too cool and
they don't give a [ __ ] about what you do
when they're they're trying to not do
that first thing you were able to be
complimentary of our channel and then
treat us like humans instantly and you
it was like yo dude i love your channel
do you want to get a drink and play
poker [ __ ] was that what you said
no we were we were playing uh
we were playing what hold him that night
yeah yeah yeah and then you didn't take
it easy on me you you cleaned me out wow
wow
that's high praise exactly no you made a
fantastic first impression thank you and
then stay in touch you came and visited
the house and
and here we are we got to talk about
this but almost yeah six million
subscribers later for you right yes
we're at about so we've got a several
forms do you guys have foreign language
channels no we do not you should
consider it and i can introduce you to
some of my people if you're interested
yeah we have uh it's about five on our
main channel but then another four or so
on foreign language channels that we
just give them access to our google
drive they usually translate or dub over
it and we own all the channels split
half the revenue that comes from course
sales and ad rev it's not a ton of rev
but it's like
a significant amount of our views are in
foreign countries which is pretty cool
we're legit more famous in russia on a
per capita basis than we are in the
united states of america and the
english-speaking world
that's interesting yeah now i'm curious
i first want to ask before we get into
the house by the way jack has talked
non-stop about your house i think since
vid
since i visited a men's house yeah
that's right let's just start talking
about this house so we'll get to that in
a second
why not show your face
good so we have a couple of videos back
in the day probably 2018 or 19 was the
last time i was on the camera so there's
a lot with my face on it uh but we found
a couple of things format wise the
breakdowns just do better i do the same
topic standing in front of a wall in my
own house not going to do as well as
when i put robert downey jr's face on
the thumbnail so that was the first
decision and the second is that recently
actually ben who is here with us today
has been doing the videos for us and i
realized that we had a very
personality driven channel when i was
part of it i didn't want to have to be
attached to every single thing that was
being done so i've you know transitioned
to ben and hopefully we'll be able to
transition to other writers for the
content and not have to be involved
every day with you know all the video
stuff that we're doing so that's that's
been a conscious decision that we've
made as time has gone on yeah don't you
feel like uh by doing that though you're
missing out on growing your own personal
brand yeah
100 yeah i
i don't really want a personal brand
these days i actually feel uh
the benefits of fame is something that
we were talking about i think are were
oversold in my imagination than in my
experience and i've much preferred
being behind the scenes helping people
to to grow within the business rather
than having to be the face of everything
that is said and being relied upon in
that way
and it's nice because you get you know
cool interactions with jack at vidsummit
where people recognize you and you can't
can't discount that but mostly i feel
like it puts a target on your back these
days where people
uh could come at you for cancellation or
any sort of thing i just i don't no
longer feel interested in the fame side
of things got it yeah well let's talk
about your house
i'm really curious about what's going on
with the house let's talk of giants nuts
first of all i pulled up the place is a
mansion yeah like i i remember graham
and i we went to logan paul's house i
like your house way more than logan paul
it's not my house to be clear i rent
right right right right yeah but it is
amazing at a crazy price
for some pretty crazy reasons yeah go
ahead and
so yeah
he told me that you would you would have
feelings and i'm excited to chat about
it so we
for the longest time i mean i slept on
floors i live in tiny apartments we had
nothing nice uh and then this apartment
is
it's a it's a home that i could not
afford to buy if i wanted to buy it it's
too expensive
but the amount of money that we have
made has made it so that i felt like i
could and the reasons that i wanted
specifically because it's got five
bedrooms which meant that my entire
family was able to come for three weeks
extended
and not be on top of each other which
for me is
one of the most valuable things that i
can do as i get older is try to spend
time with my mom and dad and sister and
and not uh grow to hate one another in
three days of like super close quarters
living so that's been a big reason and
then we wanted to get out of downtown
santa monica which is sort of falling
apart unfortunately i don't know if
you've been in the area these days but
often i saw you yeah i'm leaving
california and a lot of what you spoke
to uh and a lot of people have spoken to
is like
i experienced that we were in the very
center of third street and it just was
not the area that we wanted were you in
one of those apartments
oh yeah i can reveal this now yeah we
were right on exactly right yeah yes so
that area it's funny because i would
always walk by and see those places i'm
like what is it like to live there but i
envy that because i'm like i can't
believe you could literally just take an
elevator down and you're right there it
was like walking distance to the beach
the coolest when we moved in it was so
awesome
rent there was when we moved in it was
for a single bedroom like three thousand
for a two bedrooms like 4300 or
something like that prices actually went
down over covid but they didn't reflect
that for us because we had contracts
uh but yeah it was amazing when we got
there you're right next to everything
all the stores all the shopping people
coming in town all the time he's got the
bungalow if you like to go out and then
with time
they i think there was an ordinance that
kicked the homeless out of venice and so
they migrated a lot of them towards the
downtown area in santa monica
uh and i mean i've got stories we don't
need to go over them but there it became
much more uncomfortable to just walk
around your front yard
and walking the dogs became not
something that i looked forward to and
wanted to do in the same way and taking
a stroll in that area was not something
that was
uh it used to be the best part of my day
and then there was just an added stress
that i didn't want to deal with so we
moved up to malibu as well for that
reason and i set a price that i thought
i was going to pay and then i found this
house and that was like
1.3 to 1.5 times more than i had planned
on so
there's a different financial philosophy
all right how much are we talking about
how much is how much is rent i knew we
were going to ask me i normally don't
talk about the stuff but i'm on the
podcast thank you yes uh so it's 20 000
a month okay is the rent and it's malibu
it's a it's a large place uh yeah it's
massive it's massive it's beautiful it's
got a pool and it is the type of place
that i don't know i'll be able to live
forever but will be happy to have lived
in for the year that i that i did but
first i'd like to thank our sponsor huel
man i could really use some human fuel
right now graham help alex turned into a
zombie no no not humans for fuel hewl
fuel for humans fuel is a meal
supplement that contains all of the
essential proteins carbs fats fibers and
27 other essential vitamins and minerals
i'm not even kidding when i say this
guys but i consider you an investment
cooking a healthy meal can take over 30
minutes if you're a michelin star chef
like me but without proper nutrition i
struggle to work efficiently but
thankfully heels got me covered and now
i can finally not only eat healthier but
also save my time and energy to focus on
the things that really matter most to me
just mix their plant-based protein with
water and you will feel fantastic for
the rest of your day and they even have
huel black edition which has less carbs
and more protein hewlett even has hot
and savory meals including things such
as mac and cheese thai green chili and a
few others that take less than five
minutes to make fuel is proof that fast
food can be good food i love it and i
know you guys will too and right now
they actually have free shipping and
they'll throw in a shaker and a free
t-shirt so just head to heel.com ich and
that's hulehuel.com
ich to get a free shaker a free t-shirt
and free shipping on your first order
thank you so much jule and back to the
podcast and i remember back when i went
to your house you were explaining to me
some funny rules that your landlord had
implemented on you guys yes and like
weird
restrictions that they gave you yes so
they're they're
first off i really actually like them a
lot the way that the house works is they
live in the casita basically in a
separate area in the back but it's large
enough of a place that they're pretty
separate
uh but this house is their pride and joy
it's it's the thing that they love it's
got all of their furniture which is the
reason that i picked it because it's i
didn't have to bring anything because i
didn't have anything
uh but they've got
some like a 1950 motorcycle antique
that's in there it's worth a hundred
thousand dollars it's just like please
don't touch me and i trust me i don't
want to but they have all of their
furniture they have this workout
equipment from the 70s that that is they
don't want to throw out so it's just
filling up space so we're trying to like
find a room to put a set in but it's
just carved out with these crappy old
stairmasters that we have to like
put behind curtains on all this kind of
stuff so there are some weird rules i'm
not allowed to hang anything in the
house uh they asked this isn't that
weird but she's allergic cats no cats
we've got dogs so they're not they're uh
it's it is their pride and joy and so
they're very particular about like they
don't want us to make it our own they
want us to be people are they renting it
is it financial it must be it has to be
you know i it is i asked them this
question i said why do you do it she
said i like money and i i was like okay
but they're old so yes and this is and
again maybe they don't view it that way
but from my perspective i was like
you love this thing so much and you they
do have enough money like
i don't get it uh to me i would want to
enjoy the place that i they built it
themselves over many many years i don't
get it but i'm happy for it because when
there's a problem they're on it
lickety-split they're over the next
second because they care so much uh and
they rented it to me which but if they
like more happy they're renting to you
for twenty thousand dollars yeah but
realistically what's the market rent on
that place
six million something probably oh for
market
oh like the for sale sorry the market
rent yeah i would say if they if they
comparatively i would guess 30k is what
it's actually it could go for if they
weren't so stringent about the type of
person that's in there and they they
like us because it's me and my brother
they're like you guys gonna throw
parties no i don't i don't drink i don't
do any of that kind of stuff i'm not
gonna have like a big rager at the house
at this point where we're both uh
getting old and just we hang out with
our dogs we sit by the pool there's
nothing crazy going on so they are
looking for a particular i think type of
renter which is why they're happy to do
it at a discount um and maybe they just
don't know that it could go i don't even
want to say this because i like it jack
showed me your house online i looked it
up i honestly thought about 20 to 25 i
think so really realistically yeah i
think it's tough to get an actual feel
of the house though without seeing it in
person like online does not do it
justice the backyard is it just goes on
yeah it keeps going it's it's nice i i
when i was looking at comps because you
know more about the market than i do but
i for a moment in time became aware of
like what my options were and there was
nothing like this in that area um the
ones that were smaller than this were
selling for 25. yeah i wasn't even
looking at ones that were more expensive
the issue is that like you're renting it
with their furniture yeah you take the
tenant exactly cut that down 75 exactly
no hanging things cut it down further
you got to keep treadmills in there cut
it down further so it's like how many
people are going to rent this place
very few true it's going to take a long
time for them to exactly and that's why
it's the right fit for us so because
they are so particular about it and most
of the things we don't mind it makes it
makes it a good fit for us
yeah yeah that's interesting any thought
of leaving moving somewhere else yeah so
we i mean we talk about puerto rico
so we've discussed this and this is
perhaps the interesting question about
like philosophy of money which ben and i
often discuss and and maybe you have a
different take um
it california's really expensive and not
only the house but you know this the
taxes and all of that kind of stuff the
amount that i spend on a daily basis to
be in california compared to nevada is
probably over a thousand dollars a day
just for the privilege of a few hours of
sunlight and should i do that
i come to the conclusion that yes i
should because one right now i can
afford it and
there's
it just makes me marginally happier than
being in puerto rico
that's that's why i come to the
conclusion the idea of stacking up more
money while nice
seems less valuable to me than sunshine
in the afternoon
and
uh i don't know if that's i don't think
that's something that i'm going to
regret later in life but i don't
actually know what i would do if i had
say at the end of the year and i saved a
bunch of money say i had another 250 000
or 500 000. there's nothing that i can
conceive of that i could use that money
for that would add to my life and that's
500.
that's it so you need some good dividend
stocks yeah and so what is your so
do you just get joy out of uh seeing the
the pile
grow like why have more and is there an
enough number for you where it's like
you know what i'm gonna splurge i just
screw it at this point i am to a certain
extent uh no i don't look at the whole
number i look at like whatever whatever
the number is so let's say it's you know
a hundred a hundred bucks i'm like okay
now i could spend three dollars of that
yeah so i just spent three percent so
whatever that number is uh you know
three percent of it so right now i could
you know i'm really living off like the
imagine i make like a hundred grand 150
i keep it about that yeah so um so
whatever i earn more is just you know i
increase it three percent got it and so
is that
what why not spend more is it because
you don't think it would make you happy
or because you would stress about not
saving as much both i wouldn't be any
happier but also i would stress over
it's unsustainable like i know if i
spent more
if something were to happen i can't keep
that up
so i'm not gonna even try i'm gonna stay
within my means got it yeah but
there's there's a three percent of four
percent of five percent of six percent
why
why not spend like you have making 250k
here because i know that you're making
seven plus not seven plus figures seven
figures solidly right yeah yeah but
any more than three percent it's not
guaranteed to last through inflation or
a downturn that could last however long
so aren't you not spending three percent
it means less i don't know what i don't
know what it is but but mentally it's a
significant
plus or minus three percent it's it's
three percent it's like one agreement
it's like it's less than one percent i
could see a downturn
the market's down
market's down okay bitcoin's down fifty
percent well sure but i guess here's my
question
the the seems like the implicit idea is
that you wanna have enough money to
survive forever should you never be able
to work again and but the impression
that i get from you is that you are
smart people are yeah you are smart
hard-working
i don't want to have to do that that's
the thing but you do never want to give
in your own mentality to a certain
extent i think i think it's worthwhile
to be able to
you know when the sun is shining you
make hay
and an opportunity like this
i don't think
necessarily is guaranteed to stay around
for forever so uh at this time i think
it makes sense to double down when
things are working and at some points
things are going to change yeah so i'd
rather look back at this and be like all
right you know i've done everything i
could on this and things could change
got it is is there a
age or an amount that you would have to
be like the sun has been shining for 12
years i don't have to make hay anymore
or no no i think it's i think it's
slowly just you know over time i think
uh you know as as i get older i think
just the more you want to kind of just
take it easy a little bit more each and
every year i think it'll be a gradual
thing i don't think it's going to be one
day i'm like all right i'm done
you know just maybe an hour or less a
week every now and then and then two
hours a week
yeah a little bit less yeah yeah and i i
don't think one is right and wrong i
guess my philosophy which we'll see how
it plays out is i want to re
i want to enjoy the benefits of
retirement while i'm young and if i am
forced to work and to make hay uh i
believe that i will be able to do that
and i know
this is the other thing that we kind of
talked about is like
the the worst case scenario for me
is
living on a friend's couch because i
have done a good job of
making friends and having people that
care about me so i don't believe that i
will ever be in real deprivation i might
be in like
socially ostracized you're a big loser
you're 45 years old and you can't pay
for yourself i think that's worst case
scenario
um but yeah it's up for me to conceive
of of
true calamity uh
barring the total collapse of the united
states of america in which case i'm
screwed anyway like i don't know how to
work a gun and i can't make my own food
so yeah i'm in trouble
jack told me that you are thought would
be with that amount of money why not
purchase a smaller home own it build
equity those sorts of things right
uh yeah preferably not in malibu yes
what is your opinion on malibu uh i i
think if you live in malibu you may as
well live in ventura for half the price
i mean what's the difference very little
you're driving an extra 35 minutes
north
uh and everything's half off yeah so i
would rather do that
or move out of state entirely because
your voice doesn't your your image
doesn't need to be attached to this
channel so why why live there yes
so
i guess it's a few reasons when i think
of
the things that matter to me in life and
i've tried to take stock and i've lived
in a lot of different places
weather comes up very very high on the
list and so southern california as
compared to here for instance in vegas
where it's like low taxes that's why we
stay in california
uh instead of ventura it i've got a
girlfriend ben's got a girlfriend and it
was just do we want to live
20 30 minutes away from your girlfriend
or do you want to live an hour away uh
and so that was a decision but certainly
in the future i could see myself in
ventura um but yeah there are there are
smarter decisions that i could have made
i think the underlying philosophy though
with regard to why i chose to spend
probably more than you would have been
comfortable with is that
uh
i do
jack jack has told me that you feel that
the youtube train could run out and i
totally agree watching my ad revenue go
from 90 90.
it's okay it's a safe place 90 to 30
from december to uh to january and
that's the first day
yeah and that's and of course
we got salaries and i'm splitting with
the team and with ben of course uh
watching that is like yeah this this can
end uh but i'm under the impression this
has always been true for me that i tend
to perform better one when i have a
financial necessity like when when the
pressure is off
uh i take my foot off the gas and that's
not something i
i mind doing but i feel like i can be on
the hook
to
build grow in the future
if it's necessary financially but when
it's not i'm happy to like
chill coast enjoy got it okay but first
we want to thank our sponsor morningbrew
man i'm so tired i could definitely use
some morning brew right now me too alex
there is nothing i love more than
learning and keeping up to date with the
latest trends first thing in the morning
from a cup of coffee no alex from
morningbrew morningbrew is a company
that makes the best daily newsletter
that keeps me up to date with all of the
business news that i used to miss out on
i read morningbrew's email newsletter
every single day now and i can honestly
say that i love how easy they make it to
keep up with today's current events i
found morning brews daily newsletter
while i was uh
doing work and i saw their article on
why taylor swift's newest album was
scaring record companies and now
morningbrew even has a youtube channel i
found this really cool video of them
going into detail about how the chip
shortage is affecting our economy and
how tech companies might have to invent
new semiconductor infrastructures to
keep up with today's demand and that's
just one of many fascinating and
entertaining stories morning brews
youtube channel has to offer so go
subscribe to morningbrews youtube
channel if you're interested in business
finance or tech we have links down below
in the description thank you so much
morningbrew and back to the podcast
well before we go into my thoughts on
that how do you get started on this
channel what made you what made you get
into charisma on command yes so i was a
super super shy kid so ben my co-founder
i keep pointing to him he's hiding here
in the corner uh he was my best friend
in high school a little bit more
outgoing than me but i was especially
shy and he was my closest friend that
often translated for me to
uh girls that i might like or that sort
of stuff so when i separated from in
college especially was when i had to
start learning it uh to be more outgoing
confident charismatic because it was not
something that came naturally to me
uh
and so through
reading books and i got a chance to
study abroad and kind of reinvent myself
and sort of build the fundamentals of
relating to people from the ground up
through that process i learned a lot
about how to do it came back started
talking to friends they were super into
it and then i think i started writing on
a blog just like here's what i'm
learning eventually that became classes
that we taught eventually that became
youtube videos and we saw traction very
very quickly with everything that it was
that we were teaching it was one of the
most
uh quickly not widespread but the people
that were exposed to it were very
quickly very interested which is why it
was something that we stuck with when we
came time to you know try to figure out
how to start a business and not live a
life of consulting or investment banking
in ben's case
so it was mainly just talking about like
how to be more charismatic and stuff
like that at the beginning it was it was
very much about getting dates and girls
because i think we were trying to solve
the problem that we felt most acutely
picked up from where a simple pickup
left off because they they abruptly
ended i think right and then and then
there's this big like uh
this big market out there i think for a
lot of people especially when youtube
was becoming more popular and people
were home those are the people who
needed the dates watching youtube so of
course they're gonna watch youtube
videos and how to get dates yeah and the
videos the videos by that time in my
life the dating part was not uh it was
still important to me but it wasn't like
the the forefront of my mind we were
doing first breakdown that went viral
was of bill clinton and then we were
doing barack obama it became much more
public speaking making friends moving up
in the workplace all the things that we
found were important to people and not
just the dating stuff which i think was
over emphasizing some of the people that
i wanted to differentiate myself from
when i had the youtube channel got it
yeah but let's start with the dating for
a second i think i think that's
interesting uh how did you begin
teaching that and what strategies have
worked the best in terms of boosting
someone's confidence
so we started in new york skillshare
back in the day
did you remember that it was an
in-person platform did you ever use it
so it used to be basically a classroom
booking platform and it was you would
like say i am an expert in x y and z and
i have 10 spots and they would give you
okay come into our location and we will
be the ticket selling platform to your
class wow that was the first thing that
we ever did um we had 10 seats gave five
of them away for free on a local reddit
and then five people came through the
skillshare platform spent like 15 or
something so after the cost of subway
and you know all the food that we had to
get it was like we made eight dollars
each and the first class was how to i
think it was how to talk to girls in the
park and so we just kind of ran through
like a model for how you might do this
okay here's how you work on your
confidence here's what you can say to
start the conversation here's the things
that are important when you're setting
up a date and here's how you make it all
happen at the end of it guys were
hanging around class they were like so
when can we do this like oh i hadn't
thought about that
so then we started uh taking people out
and we would go out and very much it was
i guess the pickup model at that time
was like go talk to girls and we were
definitely trying to not be like most of
what we saw out there but this was the
business model
so we took a handful of guys out to the
park if we saw a pretty girl we would go
up talk to her if it went well fantastic
if not totally cool and teach them to do
the same so that was what started it
and then from there eventually that
became one-on-one coaching with the guys
that were most interested once that got
booked up the question was how do we
scale this and the answer was let's make
a course of what we're doing by that
point we'd realized that
the people that were most interested in
dating and exclusively interested in
dating were not the people that we
wanted to work with uh why is that
uh without
judgment or trying to shame it was like
when i went to the friend of mine and i
was like hey man i'm going to teach you
you know how to date girls he might be
interested in that but that was a
reputation that he didn't want to
associate with himself with
understandably in more mainstream
society that pickup artist stuff was
like icky and gross and anything
adjacent to it nobody wanted to be
related to yeah
so when we talked to the guys that we
most wanted to be working with they
didn't want that to be the primary focus
so we realized that in order to
attract the type of person that we
wanted and still talk about dating we
were going to have to add all of these
other pieces that were very important as
well
and that was why we focused on charisma
broadly rather than dating specifically
it was just because we wanted to
surround ourself with a different type
of person that was naturally attracted
to pure dating does that make sense yeah
it does yeah so where do someone start
if they're not confident at all if they
have a fear of going out talking to
people making friends
how do you begin people on that journey
the first i mean so we have our course
broadly and it's what i try to do is
give them the easiest fastest thing that
they can implement right off the bat and
so day one in our course is be better
than good so in every conversation no
almost everyone somebody's gonna ask you
hey man how's it going and most people
be like not bad or fine or i'm doing
good the easiest way to set an
interaction up to do well is to find a
way to be better than that so i mean hey
man i'm doing awesome or i'm exceptional
i'm great like it's been an awesome day
when you inject a little bit of energy
into the beginning of the conversation
the other person tends to give back some
and then it's much easier to make
conversation so we when we're starting
we start at the beginning which is like
what do you say at the beginning of a
conversation that is very easy very
small that evolves into longer later in
our courses and what we're teaching it
might be about storytelling and more
complex ideas of how do you hook someone
in a story and when should you digress
and tell a funny aside versus when
should you just get to the punch line
but that's it's those small things that
we try to do first when when we're
talking to someone and these days it's
almost all done through the course i'm
mostly in behind the scenes
doing not charisma stuff honestly i'm
doing more business these days yeah okay
how long did it take for you to go from
someone who is a little bit insecure and
shy maybe to someone who was pretty
pretty dang good at like being confident
better than good yeah
pretty dang good okay yeah
fantastic
exactly sure
i was listening pretty dang good isn't
that better than good no i appreciate
that he's doing it all right
i i just like that you think i got
better than
pretty dang good no so it took uh for me
months
it took a long time uh and that's
because i i was floundering in fact i
made a lot of bad decisions because
when you are not good at anything
any advice seems plausible so for
instance one of the pieces of advice
that someone gave me was when you're at
a bar and a girl asks you to hold a
drink that's like a beta move never do
that she's trying to get you to do a
favor and you can't do it that way so i
was like okay i don't i don't know any
better so when people ask me to hold
drinks i would be like can't do that no
and i would try to be some cool tough
badass until one day
a friend of mine basically chewed me out
and told me that i was being an [ __ ]
and it was like
those sorts of mistakes that i was
making because i had no way to filter
the good advice from the bad advice via
my own life experience so it took a
longer time for me to go oh that's
crappy advice and i did probably didn't
need to go down that path and define oh
that that stuff is actually good
so
months at least if not years for me to
get interesting so you could take it
from someone who you you'd listen to and
you'd put all of their advice into
action oh yeah i didn't know anything
you just believe it
and then you had to learn through your
own experience that's hilarious
funny thing i watched a guy who i
thought had great eye contact and i
determined it was because he had big
eyes which was wrong but what i learned
is when i talk to people you should do
this and for like a week i was running
around like
that's a great point i swear to god and
i think it was ben who one day i was at
the gym he's like or not the gym we were
out at a club and he goes dude what the
[ __ ] are you looking at
i was like i'm making eye contact no way
guys stop doing that it had probably
been a week of me practicing that is so
funny and it was so
and i think it had to be
there is understandably uh sort of a
social stigma that comes from having to
learn this stuff as consciously as i did
you're supposed to just get it but for
whatever reason i didn't and i think a
lot of people didn't um i'm not like i'm
aspie or asperger's or autistic or
anything on the spectrum i don't think i
just whatever influences i had in my
life didn't leave me to figuring this
stuff out so i had to learn in a very
analytical way which is the way that my
brain tends to work that's most people
now i feel like
the fact that we're spending so much
time online you get in contact with
somebody else you're like i forgot what
to do even with me if i'm working for
like a few weeks and i don't really do
anything i get out and i'm so uptight
i'm like i forgot how to act like what
do i do with my hands yeah am i supposed
to look for too long how long is too
long it's you start getting in your head
about that how about coming out of the
pandemic i mean i felt that to the
extreme not interacting with people and
then going in and trying to have a
conversation with the person who's
serving you food was just
i didn't know what to do it felt so
strange because it'd been so long away
from that world and i think if you grew
up like that for whatever reason i was
playing starcraft brood war like that
can that can be your life if you don't
intervene and do something about it
which is hopefully where our channel
comes in that's interesting yeah i felt
like it does take practice and it is
something that well no i guess not for
everybody but for me like the more you
socialize the better you get at it yeah
i mean by the end of vid summit you're
like
you you're in the flow right yeah i saw
you at the end i came and i had to break
through eight people to say oh yeah
it's graham stefan he's over here hi
graham please see me
yeah that was crazy i had two people
following me yeah uh yeah one guy was
giving me a stock tip and i forget this
i forget the stock he was telling me
about this pharmaceutical company uh but
i think he was a part of it so he wanted
he wanted me to make a video on this
company oh i remember that guy yeah yeah
he wanted me to talk about like in a
video i'm like i'm not going to talk
about a pharmaceutical company in the
video but yeah he followed me for like
10 minutes yeah to die i wish i knew
this imagine if the thing is up like a
thousand percent now should have taken
this i should have been i should have
taken it
so you said after meeting me you had a
you had a great first impression what
about after meeting graham
oh oh yeah so how about after meeting me
and give both of us things that we could
improve on okay how was that yeah yeah
i'll have to i did not come prepared i
will say um
outside you actually made a funny
impression so before we got in we were
it's
freaking cold in vegas right now we're
standing outside of your house uh trying
to knock in and we hear on the doorknob
things with the rings speak to us
vacate the premises
the cops are being called and i thought
what an impression
honestly and if there's a principle
behind that it is um it's treat people
as friends immediately oh yeah as
opposed to uh i've got to be formal or
professional i was like that i think
that's a very good initial instinct
maybe open the door a little bit sooner
because it was cold
you know the funny thing is i was trying
to get the speaker to work and my mic he
was trying to get the speaker he was
committed so he's committed to the joke
he's like i cannot let the movie out
alex and i were sitting here we're
looking at you guys trying to come in i
thought you'd get the code right dude
we're like
yeah i forgot it yeah and then i was
trying to get the speaker to work for
like 10 seconds
yeah they're fumbling outside and i mean
that was it literally i shook your hand
there and then we've moved in and had
this conversation so i'll i'll sit in we
can we can splice something in but i
that was that was the moment um
of that was the strongest emotional
feeling that was out of the ordinary
from normal interactions that popped in
my head was like oh good for him like
he's uh no seriously the there it's and
i can fall out of this i can be i'm a
philosophy major if you ask me a
question i'm going to answer it as
deeply and literally as i can but i
think the instinct to found can i say
that oh we'll bleep it out yeah yeah is
a good one it's a really really good one
and it's uh i need to do a better job of
it if i was if i was back in my career
as well i probably have to talk a little
less i i have this thing now joking
around i love scaring people you do how
many times have i scared alex it's so
much fun and you scared me yeah yeah
literally ricky scared me probably like
five times yeah joking and right right
before this podcast like as we were
driving back from the protein and
veggies wherever we ate i called graham
like yo we're heading over right now
he's like i thought you said eight
and i was like oh my gosh alex i'm like
alex he said eight right now he's like
yeah no we gotta finish we can we gotta
hurry go i called him on his bluff
though anyway you're used to it yeah i'm
used to it yeah everybody's got the
prankster friend that is just like um
yeah i would come home uh he got me a
couple times there was one where i came
home to my facebook
with a message written to the girl that
i had a crush on saying hey
i know it's been a while but i just
wanted to let you know that i really
like you and i have a big crush on you
and i want to talk to you and i was like
mortified freaked out started going what
have you done because he's a prankster
and this is exactly the thing that he
would do
and i realized they touched the screen
it was a totally photoshopped image
he was he's the type of person to put
hours of work into a 15-second prank
yes and it was good because if he had
done the first thing and actually that
would have just pissed me off and and
not been a good right but the fact that
he scared me with it without doing it
was
i thought
he got me he got me hard and made me
freak out that's a great prank so how
was jack's score meeting jack uh for
what could jack so jack and i have hung
out um now for a couple hours no jack is
uh jack's got it man i think some people
it comes easily i know it comes easily
to for some people i actually think have
you worked at all to try to be more
charismatic i have not yeah you're
you're natural honest honestly wow
congratulations
thank you
but that's because you're not jack's
date yeah so i think i think we put you
if you were a date it would uh you know
maybe things would be a little different
oh yeah is that is that the
i might honestly just be good around
dudes i think that's probably the case
you're telling me you're not good with
women
oh is this like a man running gag that
you guys have i like to think that i'm
good with them but my track record says
otherwise interesting yeah
i suspect suspect but i'll buy it no a
lot of okay so this is realistically if
i hang out with a girl there will be two
outcomes yeah okay one outcome is i end
up not really being like super into the
girl and then for some reason for the
next like couple months she's just super
interested and i just try to distance
myself and then the other outcome is uh
i just don't get a text back afterwards
but i i do after a date yeah really yeah
oh we could work on that
really if this is an actual thing that's
happening and not something it's an
actual thing no no no that's not no yeah
we can hear it i'm cool
yeah i don't know 100 it's not super
troubling to me though like i'm not
super invested in any of these dates
what the heck
what is going on here multiple times and
you'll feel like it's gone well
uh one i felt like it went well okay and
then the other ones i kind of know i'm
like you know i either a should have
made a move or b like i should have done
something else differently and i often
times like i'll feel kind of like
detached from the conversation if i'm
like with a date and i think that's
something i can work on for sure huh
we need like a hidden camera
we need a series we gotta film a dating
show that's a genius yeah a few times
because jack runs these scenarios by me
and i'm like oh it's because of this or
it's because of this there's been a few
times though that i'm like no
the only thing i could think of with one
uh it was a girl that he met and uh then
she deactivated her account online yes
and then i totally shut down social
media because of you no yeah it was such
a bad experience i think she's probably
seeing somebody else yeah or went back
with an ex
in vegas seeing someone else because i
lived here for four years it uh
not as uncommon as you like there's some
weirdness going on in vegas there's a
lot of double dealing i know girls that
like a girl that i dated the guy that
she thought she was dating prior to me i
told her that he was in the cia and what
he really had was a wife then no i swear
to god man swear to god and he would
take these i've gotta get on call and
and
i'm not kidding i'm not kidding he told
her that he was in the cia who had to
take these bit these like important
trips and couldn't tell her about these
dealings yeah
and it was i think it went on for a
handful of months like a small number of
months and then i think the woman may
have reached out to her if i'm
remembering the story correctly but
i've heard a ton of those stories in
vegas that's crazy
not not the highest integrity dating
town but not is that a surprise
like
could be some boyfriends out there and i
know that there was on the podcast there
was there was the issue yeah i explained
to him the thing with the girl
[Music]
yeah that was tough
heartbreaking heartbreaking
but anyway all so excited by the end of
the podcast yeah
all of us man yeah we were pumped true
love just
cucked yeah for those that don't know i
we basically brought on a date for me on
the podcast uh this was a long time ago
it was my first time ever meeting this
girl on the podcast and then after the
podcast i asked her on a date and then
she said she had a boyfriend and then
like an episode or two later we brought
on her boyfriend and confronted him and
uh jack what was the name of that uh
yeah confronting jack's girlfriend's
boyfriend yeah
what's the name of the podcast that was
the olden days we're different now
yeah yeah i mean fun times sure you're
like whatever it takes yeah yeah
whatever don't click out now though
click out at the end of the video to
watch one of our most viewed videos
though in the first twenty yeah it was
confronting i think it was confronting
my girlfriend's boyfriend
was it meyer jax
i want to see the face that you chose
for the thumbnail
i think it was the first time we used
the famous like the long hair just
weeping yes
yeah
oh my gosh yeah it's okay so do you have
any advice for jack could you could we
walk through something yes well well
is there a particular scenario you can
run me through the surprised you i can
try to actually uh like a scenario that
happened between a girl surprising not
call back or surprising
where you thought that it where you went
on a date and
honestly none of them are that
surprising
just being completely honest like
seriously you know you know at some
point in the interaction
[Laughter]
yeah at some point in the interaction
like interaction something probably
definitely went wrong but nothing that
serious at least in my opinion yeah so
i don't know and i also think like to a
lot of girls that i'm going on dates
with i may be a little intimidating
interesting yeah i mean are they
familiar with you from prior to the no i
i don't bring up like the youtube thing
or any of that stuff but yeah like going
to my place and seeing like maybe a
house and like you know what i mean like
i own this house i don't even tell them
that they
they usually ask me like i try to leave
some of those details out which which i
think like if i were flaunting yeah if
the house i got a car i got a miata you
know what i mean yeah yeah
are you sports car
yeah i feel like you live in a pocket
universe where where you are not
crushing it i'm blown away by this but
we we should definitely talk more i'm
okay with it you know like it's it's
really not something that troubles me
that often nor is it something where
like i'm like lying about like oh i just
wish i had a girlfriend like that
doesn't really ever happen yeah it's
funny though when we talk about this i i
check the retention rates of every video
and every single time we talk about
jack's dating the retention just goes
off people want to know why
is he struggling so much
the most interesting
we could make an entire episode i'll
give you the three the three broad
dating things that we talk about is um
and we have people self-diagnosed which
if these is not going well for you so
there's the there's the first thing is
basic interest so this is like you're
talking to a girl she says i got to go
to the bathroom that is a lack of basic
interest she doesn't even want to speak
to you really conversate well if that
ever should happen like in an
interaction not that she would take a
pee and then come back but that she
would excuse herself
and never be seen or heard from again oh
so are you in interaction is she engaged
in conversation
answering with more than one word
answers following up with questions
reciprocating interest to you that's the
basic thing and that's not sexual at all
that's like person to person sure so is
she interested the second thing is are
you communicating that you actually have
standards meaning a lot of guys the
standard that they implicitly have for
women is
are you willing like do you like me
because i'm in if that's the case and i
think this is what happens when you see
men putting women on pedestals and a
woman might say you know he'll ask her
what do you do for work and she'll say
i'm an accountant he'll go oh an
accountant that's so amazing that's so
cool and he doesn't give a crap about
accounting but whatever she were to say
it's amazing and people pick up on that
and sense that you lack any sort of
standard and are only interested in them
for their looks and that's a turn off
and then the third piece is are you
building sexual tension and that starts
with like
lasting eye contact it's the second
thing you might do is rather than
sitting across a booth from somebody you
can sit on the same side of the table or
at the bar so that when you're joking
with them you can touch them on the
shoulder or laugh by by touching their
hand or high five like you wouldn't want
to sit like we are right now on a date
because it's going to be much
tougher to establish any sort of comfort
with physical contact and then what
happens is at the end of dates a lot of
people who don't do that piece
you know you're walking the girl to her
doorstep you haven't touched all night
and it's like how do i bridge this gap
between you and me because we're not
even comfortable holding hands at this
point and i got it close to my
wow so that's those are the things that
i would ask anyone out there
self-diagnose
which is the area that is lacking uh and
if it's any of those areas there's
prescriptions that you can give to to
start to not falter so much in those
areas that's some really good advice
thanks man and it's kind of stuff that i
feel like i intuitively just know yeah
you know what i mean but i just dropped
like i said
well i don't like just reinforce it to
myself as often as i probably should
sure so
it makes sense and and if i look back on
my dates i can kind of understand why
like like i mentioned where do you think
of those three
this one ring true um
every date is a different experience man
it really is so for example one yeah
like we didn't have any contact until
the end of the date uh
everything beforehand seemed to go well
though another one i honestly kind of
rejected the girl throughout the date
which was kind of just like my bad yeah
on that uh i don't know i was just
feeling weird that day i guess
uh another one
what what other dates have i been on you
i did i didn't text a girl all two of
them now yeah that's just that's it
so i don't know i feel like i can
diagnose for the most part like what's
going on and i also i don't think i
necessarily try very hard on the dates
like i kind of just go and whatever
happens happens
um so i suppose i could also work on
that there you go
you know the answers well we'll see
we'll see
no i'm curious what about your business
because you mentioned that that ad rates
have declined yeah yeah how is your
business broken up now well good news is
that our business not dependent on ad
rates it's it's very very heavily tilted
towards the course sales that we have so
those have dipped but not nearly to the
same amount that ad rates have gone down
core sales more closely track
views that we have and the other thing
is that as we build a back catalog a lot
of the people who join our course are
not new to the channel they've been
watching the channel for two three years
so
whether or not we have a good month this
month there's still somebody who two
years ago tuned in and is like oh this
is my this is my day to buy um so we've
seen the core sales have for us
not have been close to
solid record highs for you know it's
continued to grow
so that's another reason is that even
though some of the indicators on the
business are down the business itself is
actually doing quite quite well sure
yeah could you provide some numbers oh
we
how about this do you want me to talk
about it and we can you can make up your
mind if you want us to trim it no i can
i can give you rough numbers um because
honestly i don't even know the true
numbers uh i we should probably do that
we
uh i think last year made
of revenue somewhere in the three to
four million dollar range of rev and
then that is
uh we're we have pretty solid profit
margins but we do have people that work
for us we have costs associated with
some of the things that we do um and
then i get of the profit i get roughly
46
co-founder ben gets roughly the same
amount and then we have a cmco who takes
would he like to be named his name is
ivan he gets seven percent and we're
hoping to grow that into 10 for him as
he takes on more responsibility i kind
of want like the dana white to that
that's what we're looking for it's like
i'm fatigued a brother i started the
thing
and then i want to have a front man that
is not me
uh more heavily involved with the day
today how many people are involved in
this
uh so
it's a lot there there are several
people that have like part-time things
but the core team is uh depending on the
time is roughly 10 people and then we
also have these language channels which
if you multiply that out there's 30
people within their teams because they
each have you know one the russian guy
has like 10 people that work with him
um so there's there's quite a few but
they're not all ivan is are you
chit-chatting over here do you
32 total
yeah
got it but they're not they're not all
like directly
the the reason that i don't feel as
nervous and i would if i had 32
employees that were like every month
they're on a salary i'll the vast
majority of those people are on a profit
share which is when the profit like i i
can't owe more money than i'm making
because we're sharing in the profit
together which makes me feel much easier
and i wouldn't want to
coast if i had an operation that had
super high overhead that would make me
that would make me nervous for sure walk
us through the process of making a video
how involved are you like what do you do
yeah it's been nothing nothing it's been
a year since i've been involved with the
videos yeah yeah that's crazy to me yeah
see yeah all of this so far i'm like
that's good that's what impresses me
yeah so wow that yeah well good news bad
news
i turned it over to my co-founder ben
and so he makes he's very involved uh
but we've been able to get more and more
help as time has gone on so when it
started it was uh i would
decide on a person or idea that i was
interested in say it was donald trump at
the time and those were the fun ones
because i did not understand donald
trump i was like why is this guy popular
and so it was fun to watch the videos
and sort of figure it out
uh i watched the videos and i'm keying
in for the moments when the audience or
i have an emotional reaction to this
person like i like this person i dislike
this person and then when i find those
moments i'm reverse engineering what
they're doing that is creating that and
i bundle those all together throw them
in an outline and then write a script
off the back of that
very quickly in the process because i
started also editing the videos we
outsourced to an editor who would then
be in charge of getting b-roll
um and now we have that that initial
process is done in tandem with a sort of
a junior writer that we are training
right now i am not training ben is
training right now to help us with that
whole video process but our goal by the
end of the year our number one goal for
the business is not related to revenue
it is to have our junior writer level up
to writer writer and have us receive a
video that we did not have input in that
is up to our standards and we are ready
to put on the channel if we can do that
by the end of 2022
i will be thrilled and i know benny ben
will even be more thrilled than i am
because he's making the video how
difficult was that to turn over to
somebody else because you're doing this
channel in the beginning i mean this is
yours did you find that it did
better with you behind it you kind of
like going through everything
putting your own touch on things yeah
there was a there was i think an
investing in like when ben came in he
had never done it before yeah um and so
if you looked at our best months it was
oh that might have been off our best
month but i actually think our best
month ever i think was when ben and i
were splitting videos or he was making
some of them so
it was easy to turn over to ben in a way
because he had been with me through
since i'm
13 14 years old like he's my best friend
forever and so he saw the whole process
he was a quick study relative to
somebody totally fresh there was that
emotional component of
people are going to think this is me
what are they going to think i don't
actually think in that in exact way that
ben does i don't you know uh
that nervousness but i've uh gotten past
that these days i what i more felt was
stress of being responsible every week
to come up with a new video and i was
ready to offload it at the end of it i
got burned out i never thought it would
happen because i would watch these
creators talk about burnout
and i really felt that i had said all of
the interesting things that i had to say
and was just repeating myself which
i'm a fairly creative person
drove me nuts like not covering new
ground to me was very stultifying and
boring so now i told jack like we're
starting at dungeons and dragon show i
suck at dungeons and dragons i don't
know anything about it but it's fun to
do something that i don't understand and
know how to do well that's that's where
i get the most enjoyment god i got it
yeah how long did it take you to get
burnt out
from 2015 to about two three four years
for me to get burned out of a video a
week i would say uh and then
then it's taken about
six months
yeah
yeah about and i it i i got to do and to
his like i got to do a lot of the fun
ones i got to take like the super
charismatic marvel actors and do
uh robert downey jr and now he's like
who's left and i've done i've done most
of the people we would want to do so it
does feel like what is cool what is
interesting about what you do is
some of what you cover is news related
so there's always something right to
cover uh
i'm trying to make a channel that could
mostly be i've said it it's over like
human interaction hasn't changed
tremendously since 2018 so just refer to
an old video
and that is kind of how i feel of what
i've said i'm sure there's some more
that could be added around the edges but
i am not the guy i feel like that has it
anymore i really said my piece in that
domain so
i wanted to
step aside and learn how to be a good
boss a good trainer all those sorts of
things rather than being the content guy
and what about now do people look for
like uh do your people look for what's
in the news and be like all right we got
this new rising star we got the weekend
what's cool about them oh no that's
that's oh my gosh if you guys did island
boys
why people hate or love
the island boys we i did a a video on
the second channel on the island boys
that was one of our most viewed videos
in the first like three to four days on
the second channel so these on the
island boys i've seen a photo of them
that's all that i know about them yeah i
don't know i don't know anything about
the island boys so
you gotta start tonight
that's your next viral video i want but
i want you to make this video oh yeah
i i happen
please please if you trust charlie is it
going to happen no there's no way
there's no way it's going to happen
what if you trust me on this one i said
it's going to get a million views
you can almost guarantee if you told me
he's going to get 10 million views i
wouldn't do it i have enough views i
have enough money charlie is literally i
i realize this you are the exact
opposite of crap
you guys are so similar but
completely obviously you know when you
are completely detached from views and
money you are extremely attached to
views of money you got to be the bottom
line
someone's gotta
do it
well jack told me he said and i think we
have this in common he said that
graham's the type of person who like
only does what he wants and what he
wants to do is
work related stuff and i'm the same way
except work related stuff doesn't make
it into my only wants to do category
yeah uh but yeah so
why not do it because the prize is a
thing of which i already have more than
can make me happy uh i think part of
like the process was and i there was a
time where i would have been like oh
[ __ ]
jumping yeah exactly but i'm sure i
really am curious for you um do you
still have goals because what i found is
like my first goal was say a hundred
thousand and then a million
and i just watched the goal posts get
moved while my satisfaction with the
completion of those goals did not rise
and so i got
i got turned off to the whole process of
trying to grow past a certain point of
enough which for me was like
i can cover my rent i'm not worried
about food and
uh i don't sweat it when we go out to to
eat or something like that that's
actually like the amount of money that i
would i definitely want to work to have
yeah um but yeah i'm curiou that's is
that ring
true or not really no no i just enjoy it
i would say there i've this was a good
week for me i've had a good week um
yeah no i i would say it's sometimes
like day by day some days i'm like i
just don't feel like doing anything but
i do it anyway because i've kept the
schedule i don't want to break the
schedule uh but then other times like
this week there's so much like i feel
like there's so much new happening in
the markets that like i was so excited
yeah to be able to make a video and like
post it and like i'm really proud of
these videos and i just i just love
doing it
so um yeah i don't know probably
80 percent of the time it's just i
that's just what i want to do good i
just i really enjoy it and then 20 is
like that's part of the grind yeah i
can't miss an upload i'm going to post
something today what can i talk about
that makes sense i guess
do you feel like your drive to do it
these days is more
joy-driven or anxiety-driven meaning
you're trying to avoid the anxiety of
not doing it or there's a joy of the
creative process that you want i enjoy
the creative process and i like i like
having that schedule and sticking with
it i i think i take a lot of personal
pride in the fact that uh i don't miss
uploads yeah man if people for now but i
i know i'm sure at some point that'll
change sure yeah yeah and and
i think i there was a time for me where
it was joy driven i'm and there of
course there's always a balance of like
oh i'm nervous that i don't want this
thing to fall apart but there was a uh
discovering that was going on when i was
like more learning the stuff doing the
people i was most interested in and that
phase ran its course for me
and then it became the reason that i'm
doing this is because i'm anxious about
losing what i've built and at that point
i
uh was like okay i need to go find
something that genuinely sparks my
creative juice even if i suck at it even
if it doesn't make money because i did
charisma for five years before i made a
dime and i'm willing to do dungeons and
dragons or explore psychedelics and open
a clinic for five ten years because it's
it's what i like to do
uh
and then maybe there will be money at
the end of that because i'll have become
one of the people in the world that is
most fascinated most obsessed that's
kind of what i've realized is that i
monetized my obsession and then i and
then the obsession died and so trying to
keep that
thing going would just uh defeat the
purpose of why i did it in the first
place which was to be free to choose how
i spent my time
that's good yeah i like that
see
this is easy man it's not bad birds of a
feather
wow
jack told me he's like graham is going
to get you on that house he said graham
is going to hear he's talking about it
so one thing graham would get you on
that you mentioned to me when i went and
visited your house is the fact that you
said when you're making like five grand
a month 60 grand a year you already
hired someone to do your laundry oh yeah
well this is do you not have this i
actually think if you're interested in
making more and growing i think you'd
benefit tremendously from this so he
told me that your team is like almost
nobody you guys don't have virtual
assistants you process your own refunds
do i
why don't you have a virtual assistant
for what
uh to to make sure that your brain isn't
going away from the valuable things that
you do
that you're uniquely capable of so like
doing your own laundry processing
refunds that's time where your brain
what i found i don't know if this is
like you is that
it's not when i'm sitting in front of
the computer it's that like slow churn
time which can be interrupted with
stupid tasks that people can do for 15
an hour and if when you outsource that
my output got a lot better and went
through the roof and i started yeah i
don't know i feel like my system work i
mean
i think it works and it's like if it
works why
you know why try to fix something uh so
in a sense because really my workload
hasn't changed that much it's a lot of
the same stuff
i feel like you know i got alex
processing refunds uh
you know the most i can think of is
someone to go through my emails but even
then it's like usually in a day there's
only maybe two things that that are even
worth responding to and those are things
that i just need to respond to anyway
sure
yeah
so we had i guess we had a lot more
customer service things we had editing
which i didn't want to necessarily be
involved in uh
and
your business might be different what i
found is that for us my the thing that i
was uniquely good at
was writing the videos i was not
uniquely good at responding to emails
doing laundry uh preparing my own food
any of that stuff and so when i spent
money to free up more of my time
we made a lot more money um and that
that worked well for me and the added
benefit of i don't do laundry make my
own food like i'm
it's there's something wrong with it two
degree because i've become totally
dependent upon other people to function
uh like a normal person like i wouldn't
know where to find the detergent to do
my own laundry these days um but that
it has actually wound up being in you
know special helping me specialize more
and do the things that are most valuable
to the business when i'm working on the
business
and these days i've taken more time away
from the business yeah i don't know i
try to keep things simple the only thing
i would i would think about is hiring a
uh hiring a uh someone to cook food and
bring in like do that like three times a
week you'll love it um yeah
i'm gonna respect macy on this she's
very like she doesn't want to do that
and she's like i want to be the one to
to cook the food this is kind of i'm
like well then
you know but but that would free up your
time like a match if you could get an
extra video a week
uh so you know what it's like it does it
doesn't make that much of a difference
someone else is doing it
yeah
yeah i mean my yeah my preference would
be give her the time back and just have
have a professional coming three times a
week yeah but to me it's you know if
she's happier the other way i don't and
that's the thing if you're if you truly
deeply enjoy cooking laundry emails
processing refunds anything do it i
don't want to i don't want to take
anyone away from the things that uh that
they really love doing but if they feel
that they ought to or that it's a poor
use of money i have found that
one ought to it doesn't make any sense
and in terms of poor use of money
usually there's a handful of if you were
to like
put the value of your time on the
different tasks that you're doing you
find that there's a huge thousand next
discrepancy between some of the things
and that that was helpful for us
yeah
i i agree with that i could probably be
a little bit better about a few of those
things
but make sense yeah what else am i not
going to like jack
um
well
when we're talking about your numbers
specifically uh the way that you're
investing or not investing that's yeah
we could yeah we could get into that
sure uh i don't like the not investing
yeah well this is this i actually this
is an area where i would love to learn
more because i am
i think the other areas i've thought
about a lot and i like my philosophy my
my investing is like i'm ignorant i
don't know a ton about it i never
thought that i would have any money
saved and now that i do
i'm not super sure of it so here's what
i've done i probably have 40 to 50
percent of my net worth in cash
come on get me down i'm ready to go
oh my god you're lucky right now you're
not lucky right now we're not we're only
down to where we were like five months
ago yeah so unless all of your cash is
in the last five months you've lost a
ton of money yeah how long you've been
cash for uh for as long as i've had
money which is i mean we started making
it a couple of years ago oh come on why
i don't know anything about it i've
never i've never learned oh yeah so
you're telling me outsource this
outsource that
you have an outsourced you're investing
exactly yeah that's costing you more
money than i guarantee every other thing
that you've outsourced yes well
you know you might be right um i think
in terms of the income generating i've
probably stopped that so this is an area
that is important i've i have outsourced
some of it to ivan who runs the business
and i actually best thing i ever did was
like what's a cryptocurrency here's
twenty thousand dollars will you buy
some cryptos for me yes and he crushed
it he crushed it this was two and a half
years ago like and how much is it now uh
he bought me 25 eth or something like
that and you've just you've just held
yeah i don't touch anything i don't
touch anything um he bought me an east
he bought me a bitcoin he bought me a
like
i've you know i was like oh cool and
then he gave me a nano and said don't
lose this
these are so i've got that um so yeah
that was a good that was a good
outsource that i did back in a few years
ago
um but yeah i've got a i've got a
retirement thing i've been putting in
stuff into my sep and
uh other than that i have a lot of cash
on the side how much cash
five five years of savings well for me
it's two million dollars we donate it's
we do donate a decent amount of charity
so it could be it's no it's not a few
million dollars it's like half a million
dollars is 40 50 of my net worth
i would ex okay
where's the other 50
uh i bought the mortgage on my parents
house okay uh
should charge rent there i know i could
get it
no but i've elected not to um they're
great tenants
uh so yeah but they they'd paid 75
percent of it for the long time i
started getting money i wanted to to
help with that and then some of it is
just in that retirement fund someone
went to the crypto that i described
there's a handful of random investments
some of them are psychedelic related so
like i mentioned i'm super interested in
the future psychedelics um some of them
might be confidential so you might have
to leave them some of them are
confidential so i have to leave them a
bit vague but uh
invested in uh
startups and things that are related to
that and those are like 100 that's like
a hundred thousand dollar investment i
got an opportunity i think i can say
this to invest in spacex early um so
bought just took a flyer on that for
like 25
uh and it's a it's you add all that up
it comes out to
my net worth
about a mill
about jake yeah okay yeah
it's just a lot to be spending on rent
relative but it is you're able to
you're writing that off right so it's uh
only 60
because i'm not i'm not
it's a huge house and i can't
it's like
it's got a lot of and this is a
frustration with it's like i don't need
this big of a master bedroom i just wish
this could be office space yeah uh but
yeah so like roughly 20 of the houses
area that i use for sets and those sorts
of things but the rest is not
got it yeah that's expensive it's legit
expensive yeah well i would encourage
you to begin trickling that
so of the 500 000 let's just say keep 50
50 to 100 000 in cash
and then the other 400 000 trickle it in
the markets probably over the next six
months
set a plan over six months and not two
years you think go faster two years
i was thinking faster than six months oh
my god six months no i think if he's
waited five years now he's not waiting
for that dip yeah
i i
there's there's nothing i could say that
would make you dump it all in the
morning 100 oh to be clear actually
there is there is it's
it's not because i'm stubborn it's
because i don't think okay
my thought which i'm totally open to
amending is you should have enough money
for a couple of years in pure cash no a
couple of years is that success usually
usually
six to 12 months max
that's about as much as you would need i
got because you got plenty to fall back
on and and uh the chance of like the
business going belly up and you not
being able to pay your rent and all this
stuff it's chances are if that even
happens a year of runway is more than
enough time to find out another plan got
it i mean i'm 100 totally down to do
that to take to
to set a much lower threshold and then
what just put it into s p 500. yeah or
you could do what might be better it's
just a total stock market index fund
that way you're not just concentrated in
tech but you're encompassing everything
maybe like two three thousand companies
what do you think about and this is uh
what do you think about china alibaba
tencent that kind of risky yeah because
you don't really own the company itself
so the stock is like you're buying a
stock in a holding company so you know
there's some
it's a big risk a big reward um
to me it's too risky if you were to
invest 10 percent of it i was just
curious fine
well i guess the broader question is you
mentioned uh a lot of like the u.s stock
market do i need world exposure do i
need different you could
you could yeah so there so there's two
trains of thought one is that the us has
dominated for quite some time and that's
probably going to continue the other
train of thought is well international
markets are catching up pretty quick and
they might have more growth
so
you know it's it's
either one it could really pan out what
i've done is is allocated
from my index funds about 10 to 20
with international stocks
and just an international uh index fund
that's it i so you could just say i
legit will probably i will tell either
you take a note if you want yeah
what i what i would do if it were me i
i'd probably if you want a safe approach
is like 80
in a total stock market index fund and
20 with international yeah
that if that were my hundred grand
that's probably what i would do
um you know it is very safe i like it i
like safe but if you want riskier you
could you could put five ten percent in
crypto bitcoin i've got 10 crypto on
account of ivan's uh
purchasing he could just leave that
alone or you could put five to ten
percent in and fund speculative
companies like the alibaba neo and stuff
like that that might do really well or
it might just go to zero yeah i i think
the chance of those companies being
de-listed is pretty small
but you never know yeah it's a risk dude
i'm i'm totally game for this and this
is this is an area where i uh confess
near total ignorance and disinterest so
i do need to and you're dead right
outsource it because i'm not going to be
the guy that learns this stuff and
manages my own money but the good news
is you've already learned it that's
that's you're done that's it yeah
there's not much to it
it really is
if you literally just said all right for
every hundred dollars i earn 80 bucks
goes into the total stock market 20 goes
into the international and you do that
for 50 years yeah
you know what's so silly is that i have
done this in lump sums and it's it
speaks to just i guess human behavior is
that i haven't set it up on an autopilot
so like i took care of this one point a
while back and then just left it yeah i
just need it yeah i need it recurringly
established which is probably just going
to these platforms and saying take
action yeah there's everything yeah yeah
most platforms at this point have auto
invest so you could just say you know
every month i want uh 10 grand to be
divvied up this way 80 20. that's it and
you don't even think about it every
month it'll be invested
or every week that's it i got rich on
this podcast dude i got real [ __ ]
maybe the market drops
i should have stayed in cash he got 50.
i was waiting to deploy
and waiting for this imagine we dip more
than
more than the prices were five years ago
and then he's like i would have just
made out bank right now i knew i was
saving for a reason so i'm not the next
chance i'm not an expert on this but
there was something when the economy
like or the stock market boom during
corona i was like it's fake and and that
i know that's kind of a
like a crow magnet approach to it but it
does seem weird that the stock market
goes parabolic while productivity
doesn't no because yes and no in
hindsight you could look back no that's
fake but in a moment and even still now
you could consider that well how much
money was printed into the economy
a lot of money what was it uh was it 40
40
yeah so you could look at that
objectively and be like all right 40
more currency went into the market
people use that money to invest in the
market and now it's there so that
justifies the price going up and that
doesn't reflect a gain in real
productivity that just reflects this
dollar is going to be inflated if you
don't keep it in the market so just just
to keep pace yeah so it's like instead
of seeing inflation necessarily in the
price of your your bread you're seeing
inflation in the price of the stock
market because that's where the money's
going yeah so it's impossible to really
quantify how much was really caused by
that how much it's going to go down is
this the new normal is it going to stay
like we have no clue yeah
i got it i'm set i'm rich guy that's it
i thought your fear was that this was
all about
this was all sham china was gonna take
over well
well
oh no so though well yeah i can i can
pick something are you familiar with
like ray dollar has been a yeah a pretty
big uh china bull uh for a long time has
talked about sort of the end of the u.s
empire
yeah he's been saying that for a long
time yes uh it seems to be that
am i do you think that is eventually
going to happen like maybe in our
lifetimes yeah i think they're i think
they're a huge market and it seems as
though uh a lot of overseas markets are
like that's even bigger than the us and
their demand is even bigger than the us
i would not be surprised if that
continues
um can they be as innovative as the us
and can they and can they create
um
create more than what we can here
maybe probably i don't know to what
extent though yeah so i i'm thinking you
know the us is is so far proven but i
think there's more potential overseas
it's just we don't know yeah that's the
way i see it i think they're just as
likely to do to do as well but
you know you're taking a bit of a risk
that it's a little bit less you know
proven sure so far yeah and i think it
even to my concern that you know if
let's just say that my hypothesis that
the u.s is the it is a bubble and all of
this stuff is over-inflated that doesn't
mean that my money ought to be on the
sidelines it means that it maybe should
be in the european market or somewhere
else but not sitting
yeah i mean probably anything's better
than sitting but you have a 66 chance so
far i mean that's what it's been like if
you dumped it all into the market at
once 66 of the time you'll make more
money than dollar cost averaging right
so yeah yeah but dollar cost averaging
is going to it's going to lower the
exchange it's going to lower the
volatility right got it yeah and that's
what i want but two out of three times
you'll make more money just saying all
right today i'm gonna put it all in i
think i i can't remember over the period
i think it was like 10 to 20 years yeah
and that's more money doing it and
that's the other thing is i don't want
to need or touch any of this money for
ever you know i do plan like there's
there's things that are changing in the
business but i'm not planning on
completely having my income go to zero
and if it did you'd see a lot of
activity for me and other fields doing
other things yeah the goal is to leave
it in there and not need it touch it for
a long time yeah part of it and part of
it to just mentally just assume the
second you invest it everything's going
to drop fifty percent so i don't even i
don't care just even assume fifty
percent's gone anything that that drops
you know less than that it's a win yeah
exactly no if money is stressing this is
i don't know i've noticed in some ways
i've been more stressed with more money
and that's what i've tried to guard
against when i had no money i couldn't
lose any and the market went down i
didn't care and i was already sleeping
on ben's floor and so like it couldn't
get worse than that
so i want to make sure that i don't
become one of the people that has a lot
of money and is stressed about the
fluctuations of the market when it's
like you're better off than you were
10 years ago but you're mentally
screwed every time and i hear people
like freaking out about this most recent
tip that are losing their mind uh and
definitely don't want to be not even
it's not even that bad of a drop i mean
ten percent
i know i mean yeah yeah some people may
be struggling some people some people
might put your initiative it depends
what you're invested in if you're
invested in an index fund it's 10 and
it's like
you know
yeah but if you're invested in uh other
companies jack
i know a guy remember remember i was
going to pay jack
300 to sell out of one stock that we
don't have to name here
and robin hood robin hood
had he and i was going to pay him to
sell robinhood and he didn't do it
i'm bullish on it
well maybe it's worth another 20 yeah
it's just so clumsy so not only would he
have saved money that 30 days would have
been up you would have been able to buy
back in at a lower price and profit 300
and then this dip probably would not
have happened no and then you could have
affected the macro economy exactly in
america we'd all be better off if you
would have taken the 300. yeah
it's odd the moment jack bought in robin
i was telling him don't buy in it's
going to drop don't do it
bought in it dropped it just plummeted
when i listened to you you know what i'm
reminded of the way that i uh my video
game seems like your stocks like it to
me
like do you do you
matter if he buys or doesn't buy it you
just seem very interested in like it
does it matters because as soon as he
buys it it always goes down well he's
superstitious i am okay okay so you got
superstition to me it does matter okay
so it is not just like i like to play
the game and and you know optimize the
dials this is important to my future
every time jack buys something it goes
down every single time yeah every time
but i poke his buttons because i'm not
superstitious whatsoever so if i see him
buying a stock i'm gonna buy it it
bothers me so purposely i do i now have
to buy socks
and secret so he won't buy them because
i know if he buys them they're going to
go down he didn't tell me he was buying
robin hood when i bought it i just
looked over his shoulder and saw him and
i got toying around like frantically
looking at him like jack please just
just wait to buy this no
like i went in really heavy for me and
the loss is proportional to how much
jack invests oh yeah you're just like
the anti yeah rabbit's foot yeah got it
as soon as he sells that's the thing
it's the whole thing we're not selling
we need this
think of them
how about this what if i had vlad call
you it's a jack cell sell robin hood yes
i would sell he would yeah i would sell
who's your i'm at the point no it's
virtually nothing i wonder if we could
make this happen can you get him on the
podcast vlad yeah i don't think he would
tell me to sell robin you know what
[Laughter]
his own company
that would be hilarious if we got vlad
on the podcast that would be viral jack
imagine that hey
like the next day they they introduce
crypto wallets they put you know shiba
inu on there their stock just like
finally have a good net income yeah they
turn profitable don't do it stand strong
yeah it's about principal diamond hands
i bet we i bet we might be able to get
him on the podcast i would love to yeah
yeah it would be a bit of a
controversial episode yeah because
people hate him well i don't want to say
they they hate him some people just like
him it's it's it's very easy on the
internet to like to gang up on somebody
and just automatic i don't like them
yeah so and i'm not like you know
people people didn't think that you know
defending him or like oh graham's part
of the suits he's uh you know i don't
care but like objectively people you
know it's in some of the internet
comments there's uh they assume that i
have a lot more control over the world
than i do that i'm like part of i've
seen on occasion some comments that
intimate that i have uh
i don't know that i'm part of some elite
group of people that that is uh making
videos for any other purpose than just
to get views and sell my course that
it's actually some you know that you
would have influence over robin hood for
instance being in the same vein of thing
that you would be related to that
somehow because you're a finance
youtuber that they would contact you and
then pay you to say nice things about
them i think that people overestimate
uh
the amount of people trying to influence
what i say it's it's zero
yeah yeah like donald that was that was
it yeah donald trump his people must
have gotten in touch with chris oh
yeah what no nobody no
nobody gets a [ __ ] what i say i was
actually hoping that uh the democrats
would reach out to me when they saw that
video
didn't happen
wow yeah
it didn't happen they didn't they didn't
want my strategy i had a good one i was
ready
what would have been the strategy oh it
would have been like it would have been
uh so hillary at the time this is 2016.
was leaning very heavily on uh her story
and it was like very leaning heavily on
the fact that she was a woman and i
think barack obama set the example which
is he was a black man who became
president but did not run on being the
first black president that was not his
his mantra and i think for hillary it
was much more what she drove at uh her
her attacks on donald trump at the time
were she sort of bought into his frame
if you it's been a long time but if you
remember back to the election donald
trump framed himself as an outsider as
you know that he was going to come and
drain the swamp and hillary instead of
going
why the heck would you want an outsider
like i was there when osama bin laden
was killed i've done this job better
than other people i've got
years and years of experience this guy
only has failed hotel chains she said
you know who could be more of an
outsider than me the first female
president which was just totally
uh an unbelievable claim to make that
you hillary clinton who lived in the
white house are an outsider so she
bought into the framing of
what makes a good president that donald
trump had set up and if she had instead
said i'm going to set the frame for what
makes a good president someone with
experience someone who is serious
someone who doesn't you know call other
people names and that's that's how i'm
going to do things i think she would
have had a much much better chance of
yeah
so what have you noticed with trump
because you because you were mentioning
frame setting and that is something i i
actually never even thought about until
you mentioned that that
he could go in with a narrative and
other people feed into that yeah i think
unconsciously even if they don't want to
feed into it they end up doing that
which i think is really interesting he
was he dictated the terms immigration
became an issue why no one else was
talking about it no one else cared when
he talked about that we need a strong
leader and jeb is weak everyone
rushed to prove how tough they were
instead of like
why are why is this guy dictating the
rules of the game because when you think
about it a president what makes a good
president well in 2016 donald trump got
to decide for the entire field and he
picked things where he would excel and
everyone else just reacted to it so yeah
a lot less reactivity to his campaign
and a lot more and this is what people
have you know joe biden actually won on
this um but i think standing for
something would have done much better
for
uh hillary and framing it you know about
the experience thing that we talked
about would have been a much better call
joe biden was very reactive to donald
trump and just kind of ran as the i'm
not donald trump candidate that actually
worked out for him yeah and i think
probably could work out again given
given his success and how many people
learn to hate him over the course of his
time in office
that's fascinating would you would you
ever run for president no no no no no
it's worse job ever i would never you
wouldn't no even if someone just said
all right you can i don't have to
campaign
fix our problems i mean you've heard
you've heard my work ethic i think i'd
be a poor president i don't outsource it
hire a virtual assistant like
take care of this meeting my yeah my
team my crack team
no that's i would definitely not want to
i the white house would be in malibu yes
exactly landlords i want to if i do
things in the future like i said i would
be to uh have a like psychedelic trauma
treatment clinic i think is something
run a dnd show and potentially a video
game studio one day but those are all
nice to haves definitely not politics
and what's like the the time horizon on
those
uh when possible
oh asap no no uh so we're actually i
mean we're gonna be putting a d and d
show up within the next couple of weeks
that's going up if you guys are in town
you want to hop in for a game you guys
are welcome you want to do some dnd
graham i'm not good
have you ever tried i i've i've watched
it done you've never done it though yeah
no it's it's it's
so weird and it's like what what is this
ridiculous make-believe game that these
34 year olds are playing i i get it
it's uh i just love it i have a great
time with it and so to sort of the
friends that i play with
but we've got that show coming up uh in
a few weeks hopefully so that'll be out
psychedelic center time frame when it's
legal they're legalizing it in oregon
mushrooms at least will be legal within
two to four years ketamine is being
legalized all over the u.s i am a big
fan of for treatment mdma for post
you can have what is it ptsd all sorts
of things are are well done anxieties
i find and often hidden anxieties things
that i didn't know that i had
i'd be really curious if you took mdma
what you'd get out of it
you wouldn't like it because you'd come
out you wouldn't be working as hard wow
any potential to change or alter my mind
yeah no i have no desire yeah and it
does it
if it works it it takes away edge for a
lot of people it takes away the um and
it not like the chip on the shoulder the
drive that this because it it forces you
to answer some of the questions like
why this edge why this thing um which
i've appreciated but i totally respect
people don't want to do it yeah i have
to put it into your drink secretly
it should be kicking in any moment
so thank you so much for coming on i
really appreciate it and thank you guys
for watching make sure before you leave
subscribe hit the like button make sure
to get your free stock down below in the
description sign up for public but more
importantly subscribe thank you guys so
much for watching thank you and until
next time thanks guys
uh really quick can i have you look in
the camera yes